et puis victor hugo superstar
l'adaptation de son mélodrame lucrèce
borgia par la comédie française est un
véritable succès salle comble tous les
soirs à l'opéra comique puisque la
comédie française est en réfection
l'histoire d'une femme mangeuse d'hommes
l'une des plus grandes criminel de son
temps reportage dominique poncet
échanges mines angoisse prenez un
monstre dit à jour victor hugo mais
donnez lui le visage d'une mère et vous
verrez que ce monstre en dépit de ses
pires turpitudes parviendra à émouvoir
et à faire pleurer quand même
et pour prouver qu'il avait raison hugo
écrivit lucrèce borgia cette pièce le
cendre semblait à quelque chose comme de
la tragédie quand même peut-être
tragi-comédie à des moments mais c'est
comme ça la vie parce que vous le
faisiez parce que vous êtes
ça se joue droit et les sentiments sont
vrai tout est carré c'est que c'est
c'est comme devrait être populaire c'est
ça qui vous
j'ai dirigé des bobos partout et je sais
jamais quand je lé fais que sur scène on
les sent pas bien ensuite je compte un
petit peu les les bleus craint avoir
mais moi j'aime beaucoup ça ne me
dérange pas j'aime bien j'aime bien
qu'on m'ait demandé de m'impliquer
physiquement il y à tous dans cette très
belle mise en scène tout c'est à dire la
fougue l'élan livrer ces mêmes
l'outrance de victor hugo 7 qui pressent
borgia se déroule à un rythme de western
porté par l'interprétation souveraine
des comédiens français
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]